we have always been afraid of the dark
ancient ancestors of mankind built fires
to chase the shadows away to keep the
thick black mystery of night from
encroaching on their fragile little
homes with all of the teeth and claws it
hid within its depths from the time we
were small children we knew to be
nervous when the lights went out we beg
our parents to leave the hall light on
or plug in a nightlight praying that a
tiny sliver of illumination will protect
us from the monsters we just know are
salivating beneath the bed scratching
against the closet door
waiting for us to close our eyes we pull
the blankets tight over our heads
heating the air with our panicked
breaths and reminding ourselves that the
shadow in the corner of the room was
just a rocking chair or a coat rack we
pretend it's the truth but there's a
reason we fear the darkness as much as
we do
it's inherent it's a memory passed down
from generation to generation ever since
we first learned how to scream as adults
we try to tell ourselves we've outgrown
those childish fears and night terrors
we know better now but you still run up
the darkened staircase as if something's
chasing you and your heart jumps into
your throat when you hear a sound after
midnight call it el kukui the clud the
boogeyman or a thousand other names we
all know there is something lurking in
the dark and it knows us too
d-class080-1 was pulled from a cell one
afternoon and brought to a containment
chamber he knew the drill by now they
would send him in and he would encounter
something bizarre horrible and
potentially deadly maybe he would emerge
traumatized maybe he would lose a limb
or maybe he would never come back out at
all a security guard opened the door and
instructed him to enter it wasn't an
ideal situation but he really didn't
have much of a choice and so he walked
inside dr smith called to him from
outside the room asking him what he
could see inside it was pitch black and
he couldn't see a thing and he told the
doctor as much but then
the hairs on the back of his neck
prickled a chill rippled down his spine
he had the distinct feeling that
something was looking right at him
watching
waiting
did you just let something in here he
asked it feels like something's watching
me no d080-1
dr smith responded we did not let
anything into the room the man's hands
were shaking and he could feel sweat
beating on his forehead that couldn't be
true he wasn't alone in there there in
the corner there was a black mass
large and somehow even darker than the
rest of the room he could feel its eyes
on his
boring into him his heart thudded in his
chest and he felt like he might be sick
he tried to take a step back but his
ankle folded under him and he collapsed
onto the floor what do you see dr smith
asked the man struggled to find the
words the
the giant blackness like someone's just
standing in the corner
oh god it's looking right at me let me
out he climbed to his feet and he felt
his way along the wall until he reached
the door and began to pound against it
with his fists the doctor refused to let
him out until he described the being's
appearance uh it looks like a figure
hunched in the corner is it human dr
smith asked though he knew it was too
dark for the doctor to see he shook his
head ah no it's too big to be a human
it's still looking at me doc still
staring though he should have had
adrenaline pumping through his body he
felt suddenly
sleepy almost unable to keep his eyes
open move closer to it dr smith ordered
the d-class obeyed though he swayed on
his feet as he walked it's eyes look
like
paper
just staring at me
it wants me to do something
at this point he fell to the ground
again suddenly silent dr smith called
out to him again and again but the man
did not respond when the research team
opened the containment chamber several
minutes later
d080-1 was gone he was lost to the thing
that waits for us in the dark he was
lost to scp-080
this was the first in a series of tests
that a foundation research team headed
by dr smith performed in order to better
understand this shadowy figure and
determine whether or not it has a
physical body of any kind when the
results were determined to be
unsatisfactory another experiment was
conducted a woman referred to as
d080-2 was selected and sent into the
room this time they would attempt to
have the d-class touch the entity upon
entering the chamber
d-080-2 remarked on how dark it was and
how difficult it was to see anything
inside after several minutes however she
noticed something standing in the room
when prompted the only descriptor she
could give was that the entity had two
eyes dr smith asked her to approach the
entity and report any changes as she got
closer she became increasingly drowsy
and exhausted when she reached out to
touch scp-080
she went quiet and did not respond to
any additional questions she was found
asleep in the corner of the containment
room and was immediately examined by
medical staff no adverse physical
effects were found and an interview was
conducted to determine if there was any
residual psychological impact in her
interview
d080-2 was noticeably distant her
expression and tone of voice both
described as spaced out when asked about
her encounter with the entity she became
increasingly upset and began to
hyperventilate she screamed
it just stared and stared not moving but
i felt something i was on the floor and
they were all over me they're here no
they're trying to take me away back to
the that thing
i won't go back you can't make me go
back in there at this point she lunged
across the table and attempted to attack
dr smith she was removed from the
interview room and later terminated a
third experiment was conducted using a
man referred to as d080
in order to counteract the entity's
tranquilizing effects he was given a
powerful amphetamine at a dose that
would keep a person under ordinary
circumstances awake for at least 36
hours when he entered the room like all
the others d-080-3
saw a shadowy figure standing in the
middle of the room he was told to stand
still and watch the figure and report
anything unusual that he might notice
after 10 minutes the subject became
frightened and demanded to be let out of
the room he pounded on the door and
attempted to wedge it open when he
failed to open the door he lunged at
scp-080
and attempted to hit it with his fists
he promptly slumped on the floor and
went silent his dead body was found in
the room after the experiment and an
autopsy determined the cause of death to
be a severe heart attack the researchers
who entered to retrieve the body felt
unsettled as they did so reporting a
feeling that scp-080 was looking
directly at them the entire time
following the conclusion of these
experiments the research team was able
to draw several conclusions about
scp-080
it causes debilitating drowsiness in
anyone who enters its containment
chamber after 30 minutes of exposure
anyone who is observing the entity will
involuntarily fall into rem sleep if
there is any light in the room brighter
than a standard children's nightlight
the entity will disappear
this should be treated as a containment
breach if and when this occurs after
conducting their experiments dr smith
and his research team began to
experience highly upsetting dreams while
many of the staff began requesting
appointments with the medical team dr
smith refused to discuss the nature of
his dreams with any on-site
psychologists insisting that he wasn't
going to let some silly nightmares get
the better of him as the weeks wore on
however he became increasingly withdrawn
his colleagues noted dark circles under
his eyes and noticed his near-constant
consumption of coffee that far surpassed
anything they had seen from him before
he seemed as if he was terrified of
falling asleep one day the exhaustion
caught up to him and he fell asleep at
his desk everyone in the building heard
his screams and when a security guard
eventually shook him awake his throat
was so raw from crying out in terror
that he was coughing up globs of blood
dr smith begged to be given an amnestic
to help him forget what he had dreamed
about forget all his dreams but his
request was denied he was placed on an
indefinite leave of absence and sent
home two days later the research team
was given a somber report dr smith had
leapt off a bridge following dr smith's
tragic demise the rest of his staff were
given notebooks and encouraged to keep
dream journals during the course of
their research in order to track the
psychological impact of studying scp-080
additionally they were required to turn
these journals into site psychologists
for review particularly if the dreams
became especially disturbing or violent
the following are excerpts from some of
these dream journals research assistant
megan vaughn last night i dreamt i was
lying in my bed not my bed now in my
apartment but my childhood bed with the
baby pink sheets and the quilt my
grandmother made it felt so real every
detail my dollhouse in the corner my big
teddy bear my tea set and my closet i
was lying on my side with my head facing
my closet i used to be so scared of that
closet every night i would sob until my
dad checked it for monsters i couldn't
go to sleep until he did but in my dream
i knew he hadn't checked and i just knew
there was something in there waiting for
me to close my eyes so i didn't i just
stared at that closet door and i waited
for it to open i started hearing this
scraping noise like dragging something
sharp across a wooden surface over and
over and over again but the door didn't
budge no matter how long i stared at it
all the while the noise just kept going
scrape scrape and the sound of soft
raspy breathing but the closet stayed
shut eventually i rolled onto my back
and there it was on my ceiling hanging
over me with its upside down head and
round open mouth an old woman with long
stringy hair and fingernails as long as
my arms she was scratching on the
ceiling and waiting for me to look i
couldn't move i could just stare up at
her as she took two of those long long
fingernails and slowly inched them
towards my eyes and then i woke up i'm
scared if i go back to sleep she'll pick
up right where she left off dr owen
coley i'm swimming in my family's pond
and it's a beautiful sunny day outside i
can feel the sun's heat on my skin and
the crisp cold water cooling it every
time i dip under the surface i decide to
swim down towards the bottom and die for
rocks and when i come back up suddenly
it's dark it's the middle of the night
and the water doesn't look so clear
anymore i can't see the bottom i can't
see anything around me at all and i feel
something slither against my leg i can't
get away but i just feel something else
on my other side slimy quick i can't see
it but i can feel that it's much bigger
than me so i start swimming towards the
edge trying to get out before something
worse happens but i feel this sharp pain
like a hundred needles stabbing into my
back it hurts so bad i see red but i
keep swimming i reach the edge and try
to pull myself out but i i can't there's
something on me it's so heavy i can't
get out i look over my shoulder and i
can now make it out it's the biggest
legion i've ever seen and it's latched
onto me i can see it pulsing swallowing
it's draining me i feel so weak all of a
sudden dizzying looked out of my hands
and they're shriveling up right there my
fingers pruning as i feel the blood
being pulled out of me my vision blurs
up and my head dips back and i'm sinking
down into the water as the leash keeps
sucking pulls down into the muck at the
bottom and everything just goes dark
researcher kathy levine okay in my dream
i was in my old house back when i lived
out in the woods no cell reception and
no neighbors i was in the shower washing
my hair i think it's so hard to remember
the details i don't remember the details
of dreams very well but i'll do my best
this part i do remember i heard this
sound like footsteps coming from the
floor above me that quiet thudding sound
coming down through the ceiling i turned
off the water to listen better and there
it was again definitely footsteps
someone was in my house i threw on my
clothes and i slowly snuck out of the
bathroom and i made my way to the front
door i don't know why i just i just knew
i needed to get out of there just when i
opened it i heard the footsteps behind
me and i turned around and there was
this man there huge like seven feet tall
massive tangled beard wild eyes and
holding an axe we stared at each other
for a long time and he just
smiled like he was so sure he was going
to kill me and have a lovely time doing
it i ran out of the house and into the
woods and i i could hear him coming
after me branches hit me in the face and
cut up my arms as i ran
i just knew i had to get away but then i
started to get that feeling you get when
you run in dreams like your legs don't
work like you're pushing through water i
was running as fast as i could but i
wasn't going forward at all and then i
felt a hand grabbing my hair yanking my
head back in the blade of the axe
slicing across my cheek he whispered in
my ear and his breath smelled like
rotting flesh and i'll never forget this
next part he said we're not done playing
yet i'm gonna take you apart a tiny
pieces and save your head for last
dr robert gray i was sitting on the
couch next to my wife we were watching
television i turned to ask her a
question and she was staring at me with
these dilated pupils so big her eyes
looked all black and then she opened her
mouth to speak to me i thought but i got
wider and wider and had no teeth just
this expanding tunnel of pink flesh that
started to suck me inside until my head
disappeared into her mouth i began to
suffocate i haven't been able to look my
wife in the eye all day today other
dream journals were less detailed
research assistant matt guerro simply
wrote my dog ate me while senior
researcher barbara bradley wrote i was
stuck inside my fish tank and my fish
were feeding me human flakes no matter
how frightening or absurd the dream
details were all the staff reported
experiencing feelings of intense stress
and panic while having them and after
waking up
scp-080 is contained in a four meter by
four meter room with a small antechamber
on the south wall providing researchers
with access to the space on the other
side of the north wall there is an
observation room where researchers can
view the containment room through a
window the window is outfitted with thin
blackout curtains which release when the
observation room door has fully closed
no one may attempt to remove
scp-080 from its containment at any time
under any circumstances no light sources
may be brought into the room and no more
than one seven watt incandescent light
bulb may be lit inside additionally no
objects may be brought into the room
that can be used to hide
scp-080 in any way anyone who breaks
these rules will be swiftly and strictly
disciplined and may be subject to
termination following incident 080-1
the containment measures have been
re-evaluated and additional measures
have been proposed during this incident
two senior researchers entered the
observation room and released the
blackout curtains certain that this was
a safe way to observe scp-080 without
being influenced by its adverse effects
the two remained in the room for 40
minutes at this point the two fell
asleep it is unknown what exactly
happened after this however after this
incident all staff suffering from
anomalous nightmares reported having
their first restful night's sleep since
the research had begun it was as if the
entity's appetite had been temporarily
sated and it had released the rest of
the team from its influence in light of
incident 080-1
a member of the research team suggested
that a d-class be left in
scp-080's room once a month in order to
feed it and protect the rest of the team
from psychological harm after some
debate and opposition from the ethics
committee this proposal was approved by
the o5 council now the entity is kept on
a regular feeding schedule and the staff
stream journals have been relatively
uneventful ever since it turns out that
sometimes the price for a good night's
sleep is just a little bit of human
sacrifice now go check out waldo finds
you scp-4885
find him and the secret at the bottom of
scp-087
explained for more anomalies of a truly
nightmarish nature